[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host styled sake I'm
super excited to be talking about
reimagining education we have Mario
Savio to joining us on the show hello
thanks for having me thanks for coming
on super excited for this episode
decided to be here for those who don't
know Mario's background Mario gávea he
holds degrees in cognitive science and
neurological Occidental College marine
biodiversity and conservation from
Scripps Institution of Oceanography and
conservation policy from UC San Diego he
also serves as board chair for
counterculture labs in Oakland and the
young presidents organization next
generation Leadership Program in San
Francisco he has spent years honing his
skills as an experience designer and
educator to create positive learning
environments for almost anyone and you
can find the links in the bio below
mario Gabi Atacama swalls counterculture
labs org and circuit launch calm all
right Mario let's start things off with
one of our favorite questions to ask our
guests what are your thoughts in the
direction of our world I think there can
be some pretty concerning developments
in the world today but it's one of the
reasons why I really like working in
education I get to see I was just at a
hack the future event a few months ago
in Lafayette and we had like a nine year
old kid that had spent an entire you
know a few months building this whole
Minecraft world and you know was up on
stage talking cogently about what he did
and all these different features and he
was really mad that he didn't you know
get the bats or something right and I'm
thinking like man this kid is already a
better programmer than I'll ever be and
he's 9 years old and he's up on stage
talking about this stuff with a you know
great presence and stage presence and
stuff so I get to see inspiring stuff
like that all the time and it really
kind of gives me hope for us being able
to change stuff for the positive as we
go forward and so then the reimagining
the education experiences for
young people is you'd say the one the
most important pillars of being able to
have a positive trajectory um I mean I
think you can change anybody's
relationship with education and learning
any time so I don't think you have to
necessarily focus on kids but you know
my education philosophy has kind of
grown out of my relationship with
education when I was growing up and I
was a really smart kid but didn't always
get along with the way that people
wanted to learn in a classroom
environment and so I had a lot of
clashes with my teachers I had a lot of
teachers telling my parents that I was
like special needs and my parents were
like absolutely not and would get me IQ
tested and there would be a big fight
about it so I saw and I felt a lot of
shame about that too because I just
wasn't you know being a good student or
something and I think it's just
everybody's got a different personality
and if I had had access to some of the
experiences that I try to bring to
people today I might have had a very
different relationship with education as
I grew older and not that I'm sad about
where I'm at I mean I think that I'm
doing really great work but I would like
to see more young people have a better
experience trying to find their passion
and kind of have a great relationship
with learning throughout their entire
lives and not just think about getting
through school I mean I remember so much
about like as soon as I graduate you
know and that's just a weird phrase to
me now because now that I'm in the real
world of my school was great why
couldn't we stay there forever and I'd
love people to have more of a philosophy
of lifelong learning and use time in
school as a time to hone how you are
going to be learning for the rest of
your life as opposed to trying to get
all your information so that you can be
immediately packaged into something
successful as soon as you leave college
because I think that's the second
pitfall people you know have gone
through all this training and everybody
in college says like ok once you've got
at graduate college you're you know
gonna be successful now and that's just
not the case for most people and that
can be a really tragic difficult
emotional situation to get people out of
as they grow older and try to find
themselves again
so I love the focus on finding purpose
of one's purpose in the world and that
can be from like he said this these
experiences of reimagining education
could be from anywhere from children all
the way to adults and having a new take
on on their own education their own ways
for learning have a be hands-on have it
be things that stick that expand their
awareness to new ways of thinking about
how intertwined everything is in our
world and how important it is to work
together these types of things that's
great
Mario let's do your journey okay so
you're telling me earlier fourth
generation Italian born in San Mateo and
then who were you growing who was your
family how did you guys get interested
in food and culture and experiences so I
had an interesting situation my dad's
family has been in the Bay Area for he's
he was third generation and so my
grandparents were born in San Francisco
and grew up and actually my grandfather
and grandmother on my dad's side grew up
a couple houses away from each other
when they were little and didn't end up
meeting until their 20s but that was
always kind of a big story they like to
bat around yeah and so we were not only
humans like deep Italian culture and so
my great-grandfather moved over here
from Italy and was a butcher and started
a salami company and then that was shut
down in World War two because of the
rationing and my grandfather started it
back up and became gallo salami which is
a big salami company and then my dad
when he was coming into his own and
professionally moved from being
management at gallo salami into a Dell
sausage which is a pretty famous it's
like the largest gourmet sausage company
in the u.s. he recently sold that to
Tyson I think and where were we going
with that the story is already crazy so
anyway so so anyway there's just a long
history of just like generations of food
people on my dad's side in the bay area
and on my mom's side my mom's from Ohio
her dad was a lifelong Sales beer
salesman for Pabst Blue Ribbon and so
they're eating like microwaved string
bean casserole and you know just like
the worst and so her idea of like
gourmet food was pretty different than
my dad's family's impression of what
gourmet food was so I was kind of
growing up in this place where I not
only got like the most intensive food
education from these Italians that I was
growing up with but I was immediately
ejected positioning that with what my
mother had learned from her family and
you know I'm not trying to like crap on
Midwestern cuisine or anything like that
but there's a lot of food culture that's
been lost when you know cultures move
over I mean I think her background was
English in German and after a few
generations of living in Ohio that just
kind of got washed out into stuff that
just wasn't super tasty it was really
fatty a little too salty and then when I
came from my background with the Italian
food it just you know was never that
exciting so I always kind of was very
aware of the fact that there were is
there's there's the ability to lose your
food culture if you're not constantly
preserving it talking about it caring
about it having arguments about it and I
got that from the Italian side of my
family so from a very early age I kind
of like we all really cared about food
we competed about food you know who's
the best cook when we were young kids
and we were always trying to like take
over in the kitchen and like show up our
parents and even now like for
Thanksgiving my mom and dad will have
like a turkey cook-off and they'll make
each a turkey and they try to you know
we make everybody evaluate what's the
best one you know it could be good and
bad at different times but I think just
seeing the fact that you know how
important food culture is and I think if
you're just steeped in it you don't
always recognize that that it can be
missing in other places yeah and I think
that I could I can see that and I was
important and it made me really cherish
it and want to preserve it yeah food
culture and food preservation this is so
important especially from looking back
in time at all the different cultures in
the planet and how they were able to
preserve their different ways of cooking
and harvesting food and
sharing it with other people having
these cook-offs making it part of
culture to make it fun and to be
connected to our sources of food versus
being just walking into the stores and
just not being connected whatsoever when
also that I mean my my grandfather and
father were into making preserved meats
which is a science so my dad's a food
scientist my grandfather you know it was
definitely dabbling I don't think he was
a professional or an educated that way
but you know having to understand that
technology of meat preservation like we
were talking before I mean it's a
technology to be able to take something
that you know you kill a big animal and
you got to make that meat last for up to
a year using just salt and proper
handling techniques I mean that's an
amazing technology so I was aware from a
really young age that not only could you
eat this stuff but there's science in
there and I got that for my dad in a big
way because he was a big part of like
trying to take the old world food
tactics he was part of the technology
saying now you get those those pillow
packs where there's air inside instead
of it being just vacuum sealed hmm so
that's a proprietary gas technology that
keeps the the bacteria from growing in
there my dad helped develop that
technology whoa
so it was kind of neat to see like the
food science really applied and that's
given me a really great kind of base for
now what I do which is trying to use my
passion for food and turn it into a way
to teach people about microbiology yep
so my gosh when you're explaining this
to me a little bit of go-to is just like
such an aha moment that if you could
only store for a couple days after
cooking something to be able especially
like a meat to be able to figure out
that preserving it with salt can for up
to a year help you be able to revisit
that source of food I mean that was a
massive discovery and then there were so
many other ways of preservation
techniques other fermentations and other
styles of preservation so huge I love
the the big deep time perspective on on
how these things came up this is a funny
thing I was talking to some people
about Game of Thrones so this is this
whole area where you're supposed to have
like these giant long winters and you
know and I'm going like agriculture
would have been completely insane why
isn't everybody eating pickles all the
time yeah because if you have some like
seven year winter your entire like life
would be about preserving food whoo you
know I'm seeing the fresh vegetables all
the time and I'm like this is crap you
can't have I mean you know armies march
on their stomachs is a famous line you
know March so if you can't feed your
people you know you have a big problem
on your hands so these kind of food
techniques people can talk about like Oh
food isn't that important or something
but you do it three or four times a day
and the if you don't know anything about
your food I mean then this seems like a
nightmare to me yes if I'm gonna be
interacting with something on a daily
basis multiple times a day and I just on
my health on my well-being on my social
relationships this is a big thing that I
talk about when I do my classes at the
Culinary Institute because these are
these young chefs and you know they're
going into this culinary industry and
it's very difficult and there's a lot of
light hours and people are you know
doing these different things but if you
really think about the job that they're
doing they're bringing people around a
table and if you can tell a story with
that food about your cultural past or
you know some path that you've been on
through these foods that you're giving
to people I mean giving someone a food
with a really good story that's the
difference between Chez Panisse and you
know Domino's so if you can really get
people to focus on that I mean I think
it's a really important aspect you know
people don't always know the power that
chef has to get people you know that
don't agree with each other to sit down
and have a great meal and that can
really open some doors so yeah yeah yeah
Wow and and it's one of those things
like you said that happens three times
nowadays and that even our sources of
water are so op he skated right we're
not and where our hands aren't in the
soil growing the food in the gardens
these are very pressing things that we
need a challenge our society on is that
by moving away so many of the means of
understanding where our water our food
our electricity all these things come
from that is it actually making it
easier for us to
to have a more connected life with
mother nature with each other or is it
just said offsetting it to someone else
to handle while we do things that we
deem as productive but disconnecting
from potentially each other and our
planet so this is one yeah I'm glad that
you're bringing that up that's a huge
one then so then but then how did it go
from the how did the interest in peak in
the cognitive science and neural marine
biota conservation conservation policy
how did all these things creep into life
these are huge fields um so I think when
I was going to college I mean I was
always really interested in science so I
loved biochemistry tons of memorization
in biochemistry and I'm not a super
meticulous person when it comes to crazy
details and memorization I'm much more
about you know if I can build a system
or if I can conceptualize how to do
something so that you know I'll be most
likely to get the right answer those are
the things I'm really interested in you
know knowing the exact name of
everything all the time is something
that I find happens kind of accidentally
for me after I'm very familiar with the
material so when I got into to
neurobiology and stuff it was kind of
because I didn't have the GPA to stay in
biochemistry but I was still really
interested in the body and chemistry and
how the mind works and things like that
so and I really had a great linguistics
teacher a lot of the choices that I made
in my early academic history was just
trying to follow educators that I liked
more than the subject matter necessarily
because I found that if I had a really
good teacher I just liked that in that
that subject matter even if I knew that
I loved the subject matter but I had a
crappy teacher I would just have a much
better experience in place where the
educator really spoke to me so that was
kind of how I felt like I had a really
good linguistics teacher and she kind of
gave me the idea that I could take a
bunch of her classes and a bunch of
these computer science classes that I
like and a bunch of neurobiology and
then it could be cognitive science so I
was like that works great but the whole
time I had a job on campus as a diver
working
for this van tuna research group which
is a really cool thing about Occidental
College the only undergraduate
institution that has a graduate level
research facility that you know uses
grants and does actual research on on
campus so I was really into diving and
stuff like that so I've got that with
them because we could also go lobster
diving but we were also doing benthic
surveys by the Chevron plant and diving
out at the twin harbours white sea bass
pens they were doing a program for
evaluating the environmental impact of
fish farming and nearshore environments
so we would dive down there and take a
bunch of benthic samples and I would go
back into the lab and pick out all the
living stuff and quantify it and count
it the things like that so that was just
kind of a real granular I got to do the
fun stuff we just go out and dive but
then I got to be in a lab environment a
lot and I kind of liked it it's like
independent there's a little bit of
thinking somebody teaches you you know a
task and then you repeat it but at every
stage you're learning about something
and you get to observe stuff about the
the environmental world and we were
really discovering new things so it was
cool to pick these little wee worms out
of there and be like I was a really
weird shape or you know this one took a
really long time to die and the
maldehyde solution or something and so
there was just a constant learning that
was going on there so then once I got
out of college I actually moved to China
for a little while and did a language
program there and then got a job with a
seafood company that was trying to
import fish into China and made like a
price map of all these different fish
that were there because I could identify
them biologically but they had kind of
different common names and a lot of
these different towns so that was a
great opportunity for me to kind of go
around and see a ton of like fish
farming operations and fish markets and
I region or what was the other name I'm
there's a big seafood conference Sebald
seafood conference that happens every
year in Qingdao China and I I was hired
on to do a little research about
different fish farming out there and
that kind of started a new chapter of my
life because I'm seeing all these fish
that are being produced for US markets
and fish farms that maybe didn't have a
whole lot of great
environmental controls maybe they were
using chemicals they weren't supposed to
be using and there's just no oversight I
mean less than 1% I mean when I did my
when I went to Scripps and started
researching this professionally less
than 1% of the fish that we're importing
is being inspected and so people know
that and since it's so unlikely that
you'll be caught a lot of stuff that
people are eating and that's why that
country of origin labeling was so
important and fish farming I always
thought microplastics is the big thing
or what's the big thing well I'm not so
worried about microplastics because I
think we can eat probably eat a lot of
little tiny chunks of plastic and it's
not going to give us cancer but you know
if we're medicating fish and I mean the
big thing I was worried about where the
salmon pens off of the coast of Chile
and at the time I don't know exactly
what the regulations are now but it was
like the Wild West when I was doing the
research and they had these net pens
they would grow out these baby salmon
they would put them in these pens and
then they would feed them all this feed
but they're so crammed together thing
that they're getting diseases so they're
medicating them with antibiotics and
then they're using all these chemicals
to keep them from getting sick or to
knock off the lice that would come and
eat the fish because they're already
like stressed so it's just like all the
sea bugs get in there and want to get in
there so now this kind of fish and and
they're harvesting and selling the fish
before it had time to show the physical
signs of disease so we were taking fish
fillets that we're coming in to like you
know at the time like big retailers that
you could buy your fish at and we were
testing them and they had all these
disease factors for like salmon
septicemia and these kind of like
bacteriological eating wasting diseases
and you know if you create a huge line
of protein that's serving these kind of
disease meats to a population it's
likely that at some point it'll make a
jump and start becoming infectious for
humans so I saw that as a really big
issue and I thought that there needed to
be some kind of like pedigree system you
could apply to fish and when I was going
to these fancy restaurants in China they
would have a grouper that they would
tell you its whole life history its name
you know where it was
where it grew up how it was treated in
captivity
you'd get to look at them and then you'd
select one and then they'd cook it for
you and stuff but they really cared I
mean like these with all these documents
were stamped and this was because people
knew that there was a problem with this
stuff this is gonna Daniel vigilant
supply chain yeah yeah and so it would
have been nice to have a system to deal
with that and I tried to develop
something with Texas Instruments where
we were using these little
radiofrequency ID tags that are about
the size of a grain of rice and you can
actually inject them into the fish and
then we could monitor them with
computers and scanners throughout their
entire lifecycle and then you could get
a fish fillet at the market and scan it
with the QR code and it would give you
all that information like where it was
born and how long ago it was harvested
and what the manufacturer was so that
you could track hey I had a really good
clean piece of fish or a good experience
or I read a good thing about this one
I'll select this guy even though it
might all be under the same you know
purveyor or something at least it gives
you a little bit of information to make
that choice but trying to sell that
technology to a restaurant or market you
know market chain they don't want that
technology because now all of a sudden
it's even harder to source seafood I
mean right now it's hard enough so the
less information that people have the
better it is as far as just selling that
protein out the door but if you really
care about what you're getting it's
extremely difficult to get store a fish
with a story behind it they make sense
and it's true and that is actually gonna
you know represent something good for
your body and good for the environment
and so it's a total tragedy now I like I
haven't been working in that area for a
while but it was enough information one
of the examples like that and I don't
eat a lot of smooth now because of that
experience which I you know that was
disease was a big of a problem we also
have the same thing coming up in close
proximity factory farming with cows pigs
chickens we have the same issues arising
and we're ethically finally growing up
in bio technologies figuring out how to
grow clean meat in bio reactors and I
think 50 years down the line kids will
say I can't believe you're slaughtering
billions of animals and so that seems
like our trajectory hopefully
indistinguishable
meats grown in bioreactor so it's a
slaughtering animals I'm curious what
your point of view is on this because
I've I'm super into the cell based meats
and I am really excited about this
technology but when I talk to people
about how they're gonna change their
eating habits as they go forward with
these new technologies they're like oh
yeah well you know when I'm having my
ground beef or something I'm gonna like
have this you know pea protein or I'm
gonna have this impossible burger but
you know I'm still gonna have a ribeye
steak once in a while well there's only
like two or five ribeye steaks on a cow
or a steer or something and the rest of
it is other cuts of meat and there's
like hundreds of pounds of ground beef
so if we're now still growing the cattle
because people want to have nice steaks
once in a while as a as a treat that
necessitates producing all of the other
ground meats and stuff that are just in
a much higher volume but now nobody's
eating that stuff so you know
are we really saving the environment
because the other thing is there's a lot
of land everyone talks about how much
land in the US has used for livestock
and farming and stuff like that but most
of them are turning totally uh narrable
land that we couldn't use for farming
anyway into some viable food source
right so you look at like Eritrea and
stuff and they have these special
gazelles that are out there eating this
like totally desert vegetation and then
they produce this like nice gazelle that
you can shoot and eat and it sustains
all these populations and stuff out
there that they absolutely could not do
with agriculture so I really love the
sell meats and I love the technology and
I want them to be developed and stuff
like that but nobody has really answered
the question of like what are we gonna
do about the fact that we have two
majorly change our culture and make sure
that like nobody wants to even eat a
steak because the second people want to
have a ribeye steak once in a while we
have the beef industry forever you know
and then what are you gonna do with all
that meat that protein that's being
supplemented by the Selmy think like all
the Yogi's know if that were used to do
need to grow like ribeye steak if you
can grow a ribeye steak all of our
problems have been solved but if you're
only growing a equivalent for ground
beef I don't think that we owe ya the
creativity is is there's it's it's it's
it's it's uh it's unbounded if there's
so much to explore in it so there will
be solutions I think for all of those
examples and also just looking back at
all the things that we used to do that
we're archaic and now just looking back
and saying I can't believe that we were
doing that I think that same thing is
going to happen okay but now let's let's
hit on on conservation policy I want to
know about this so what what exactly
were you doing in that field yeah tell
us about that
so this is part of this great program at
Scripps and scripts is kind of a it was
actually there before UC San Diego but
it's an oceanographic institution and
they have historically been very
involved in oil and gas exploration and
they do a lot of the technology needed
to do like deep-sea drilling and stuff
like that but there's a lot of people
doing like really cutting-edge coral
reef research and things like that and
they created a program I was the second
class I think so they started maybe like
2008 and it's a marine biodiversity and
conservation policy program and the idea
is that you take people who have had
some experience in the marine world to
some extent so people that are divers
that work for a fishing game or the
Coastal Commission or people like me I
was working in zoos and aquariums at the
time and they bring them in and they
give them a really comprehensive
education on what's going on in the
world what are the different systems
what are the different research that's
going on at Scripps and other
institutions that are you know like what
are the unanswered questions about the
ocean and our relationship with the
ocean yeah and then because California
has a lot of really unique legislation
we have like the California it's called
sequa Environmental Quality Act which is
a really huge piece of legislation that
gives California pretty unprecedented
presidented control of its local
environment and so governmental policies
like that have allowed us to do
California coast has about 16% of it
which is
protected marine protected areas which
is about the same physical amount of
landmass as the Great Barrier Reef has
set aside for for conservation so just
16% well I mean just 16% our idea I mean
that what a lot of scientists are saying
now is if we can set aside as a 20% of
the oceans that we'll be able to fish
the rest of the ocean as much as we want
and we won't be able to deplete it
because well I've identified the most
productive areas of the ocean and left
them alone and let them really you know
thrive okay and California has been a
leader in this but now California
because we've been such a leader in this
we're going to places like Hawaii that
actually don't have as good policy as
that and we're taking our experiences
from conservation efforts in California
and we're taking those people in that
technology and we're going to Hawaii and
we're using those technologies they have
a new thing it's a sea dart and it can
go down because there's lots of
technologies like Rovers and stuff
that'll serve a flat area these ones do
vertical so and it's super easy and
we're doing citizen science stuff with
it you can have it you know just you
know kids can take one of these cheap
things out and drop it down and and
create really great necessary data that
we haven't had before so all these kinds
of things are coming together and what
you really realize is that these
governmental policies are very very
important because without them it it
doesn't give anybody the ability to make
a change you kind of have to give people
the impression that we care about stuff
and that's really what governments for
because most people are out there trying
to fight for their day-to-day life so
they don't really have a chance to think
about like well what's a 50-year plan
what's a hundred year plan and that's
really what the government's supposed to
be for it yeah and if the government
just comes out and says hey we want to
value this resource we're gonna put you
know our resources behind identifying
and protecting these things that gives
permission to a lot of these groups to
say okay let's invest in developing
these technologies to figure those
questions out let's pay people to do
work you know and what we're finding is
that we've taken areas I mean like you
know the California coast has always
been a really productive area to fish
but when we set aside these marine
protected areas and people come they die
denta phi everywhere right around the
marine protected area and they're
getting better fish catches than they
were thirty fifty years ago so it's a
really powerful model and I think that
policy is right at the center of that
and so getting an education from Scripps
and UC San Diego on the different kinds
of policy that's going on out there it
gives you you know politics is sort of a
dirty thing these days and it's really
you know what we're looking at is all of
these political opinions and and and
stances that maybe don't give us an
accurate picture of what is happening on
a daily basis and there's so much good
stuff going on in politics right now and
there's so many people that care and you
know I'm not a big fan of our president
at the moment but he has had an effect
on people really pissing him off and
getting him involved in politics and I
remember as a young person I was
completely checked out of politics
didn't want to vote or anything and now
I am like an evangelist for trying to
get involved in politics because it's
the only thing that's going to give us a
chance on a long enough time scale to
really make some huge improvements in
our life when you think about the things
that are affecting our lives now I mean
they came out of the government programs
like the space program or you know the
New Deal or you know just things where
we like let's put our resources behind
experimenting in this area and it's
exploded out onto all these new things
you know I wish it wasn't oil oil and
gas exploration right now but what
you're saying about conservation policy
is massive and now also it actually ties
me into this next part that I want to
talk to you about which is about you
know story shaping everything the
importance of reimagining education
broadly if you think about it
conservation pause if you think about an
environment just in the connection to
nature connection to what sustains us
our disconnection from that is in many
ways the reason why we have so many of
these issues in our world do you feel as
though
so the workshops obviously that you're
that you're teaching people about tie
them directly back into that source from
where we all originated from do you feel
like that is the main central reason why
we're so I have so many of the issues
going on in our world
I mean the answer the question it's very
multifaceted I think I approach it from
an educational angle because I think
that you know if you want to have a real
appreciation for the for the natural
world
you know like growing something you can
eat is a pretty great first experience
and I think that that can give people
kind of the emotional buy-in to want to
care more
I think the disconnection really gives
us emotional distance and it's that
emotional distance that allows us to
make decisions that ultimately are
really terrible so I think that there's
there's a I think we've kind of over
emphasized a lot of the the I don't know
measurable aspects of you know education
and politics and things like that and we
maybe have under emphasized or like
underappreciated how important you know
like feelings and relationships are in
these kinds of environments so I try to
do you know I'm pretty good at engaging
people on an intellectual level or an
education level so that's kind of the
power I like to exert on people by
trying to take a little bit of the
things I'm passionate about and kind of
infecting you with that and making you
want to ask questions but there's so
many other things that are a part of
trying to like answer why people feel
disconnected and want to escape I mean a
lot of it is I mean there's like
monetary policy stuff there's you know
and like I can't I'm not going to be
able to be a strong force in that area
so I think to some extent we all have to
realize like we only can do our little
part and but doing that part is really
important you know studying a lot of it
I wanna report Rihanna I want to empower
people because I mean I think of all the
people that we're disenfranchising by
giving them educational environment so
they feel like stupid and turned off
which is like every school I go to you
know we have a lot of like expectations
I mean there's this fear that parents
have right now about their kids being
successful and then it
makes their relationship with their kids
sometimes like very adversarial around
education and that's something that I
have to they have to be following their
purpose yeah and so I have to kind of
try to help people find something
they're excited about and then use that
like here you can you can accomplish
this same thing that is gonna make them
feel like oh he's like learning or she's
really interested in this do you know
its purpose they need to also be
connected to what actually sustains them
the planet so they have to have that
realization fully embodied into them as
they carry out their purpose and the way
should love it
they should love it you love it then you
can stick with it I think a lot of
people are trying to force themselves to
do something they don't really love I
mean if you look at my work history and
it's like I was always doing stuff I
didn't love and when I hit on something
that I felt a real connection with I was
like great I don't even care if I don't
get paid any money I'm gonna do this
until I figure out a way to make it work
because you know this is something that
inspires me to do it and I think that's
the way that you really change people
you know you can't you can't not believe
in your what you're selling and have any
purchase with people you know you're
infecting people with reimagining
education and you're doing it in so many
different ways workshops on dinners
joyful personal living spaces we're
talking like all these cool images that
we have to your teaching be keeping
nature towards mushroom hunts mushroom
cultivation hardware to film and garden
design grow your own food for kids to
little chefs kid cultivators pasta
fermentation classes so many cool things
charcuterie I mean wow like the list
because you that by doing all of those
things and by taking people into all
these experiences you are then
connecting them to nature to their food
to our interconnectedness and so that
slowly infects into people's education
and want to give them to share it tell
us about how this has been this is how
many years has this been happening would
have been some of your favorite parts
about the exponent expiry
yes so I was doing like corporate
training stuff about five years ago and
wasn't really enjoying it it was sort of
educational but I wasn't really what I
loved to do and I got involved with
counterculture labs and they were really
encouraging me to teach some classes and
just kind of like share my knowledge
there's always a need for stuff like
that down there and I was like hey yeah
you know it's a it's a inviting
environment I'll just like try to you
know take something that I think I know
a lot about and teach people about it
and I would do like you know a marine
biology class like four people would
show up and then I did like a mushroom
class and 40 people showed up and I was
like well I guess I'm a mushroom
president now yeah and you know as I
kind of jumped around from thing to
thing that I was that I was just
interested in and it's a great way to
learn you know if you want to learn
something teach it it's like learning it
twice it really gets that information in
there and you know I would love to pick
something new up and immediately flip it
over and turn it into a class and you
know over the course of three years I
started noticing that I was just
restricted you know I was doing a lot of
stuff at this counterculture lab space
which is a great makerspace but it's a
little cluttered and a little bit
difficult you know especially if you're
making food in there it's not the best
environment so I found myself kind of
looking you know people were asking me
to do these other things I didn't feel
comfortable doing there and that over
time just kind of blossomed into
offering all of these different private
workshops and you know I like to work
with small groups because I think that
kind of doing a group activity together
is a very bonding experience and so I
can take something like Oh a pasta
making workshop like I do a mommy-and-me
pasta making workshop and that thing
gets emotional all the time yeah because
people are sitting around doing
something with their hands their kids
are always like engaged and quiet
because they have something to play with
it's safe for them to put in their mouth
and it's not going to be a big deal and
then the moms you're chatting back and
forth and it's like tier central but
it's great because it's a really like
supportive environment
everybody's gets to learn something
everybody has a great time you know so I
don't always look at these things as
like a reason just to learn a thing
sometimes it's a reason just to get in a
room with other people that have a
similar desire to do something and
creating a little space for community in
there we do like I just started this new
thing with Lauren Tedeschi who is one of
you yeah and she is like a 25 year
veteran of Novartis and is a protein
purification specialist but she's also a
fiber art masters like God all these
different awards for doing this stuff so
I was like great let's teach a class
we'll make these science concepts we'll
teach people how to embroider them and
people are making these beautiful pieces
of art and they're repping their nerd
pride on their pants you know if you
want to memorize the chemical structure
of psilocybin needlepoint sit on a pair
of pants for two and a half hours and I
guarantee you yeah so I can take people
who are interested in art who'd never
thought that they were interested in
science and give them something super
scientific to like maybe get invested in
you know maybe maybe they did a
jellyfish and it was just that and
whatever but they still hung out in a
science lab with a bunch of science
people and that's still better than
nothing so I love doing that's the other
thing that auger art thing I think we'll
get into more detail later but it's a
great engagement tool you know I want to
take you know I only have the ability to
take to give so many classes and at the
end of the day I really want to take
these concepts and this like love of
learning and this engagement tool and
bring it to as many people as possible
and so doing things over the Internet or
you know it's not as good as creating
community in person and coming and
hanging out but not everybody has the
ability to do that and maybe you need a
little bit of time to get comfortable
with it
so I love the ability of someone being
able to you know interact with the class
and an electronic format until they feel
like great you know what I feel
comfortable enough for them to come down
and be a part of the community and that
is the thing that changes lives it's
really cool I love that it makes you
feel so warm because you're right that
when you can give people together with
behind like a same cause of learning
some process being it together in a
community their Mommy and Me this if you
could for like faucet making or that's a
great one and then that being able to
you know that also ties me into kind of
what you're saying at first where the
child is then able to maybe you know
take what they learned and then go and
teach it right away it like take a stage
and give a presentation about it you
know these this is how you really
cultivate strong senses of energy kids
are natural at this I mean some kids are
shy but a lot of kids they don't know to
be embarrassed yet so if you can get
them to talk about stuff that they love
and they're passionate about when
they're little they'll keep that their
whole lives so I'm really I mean I love
teaching kids I mean I love teaching
everybody but teaching kids can be a
really great experience because if if
you can reach them I mean sometimes
they're a little too you know off in
their own world to really try to get
what you're selling all the time but you
can still give them a really positive
learning environment and the other thing
is like teaching 6 or 7 year olds is one
thing but I also interact with a lot of
like high school students and a lot of
them will come to me and they like see
the stuff that I'm doing and they're
like oh man like I really wish I could
do your stuff and you seemed really
impressive and I want to you know but I
like live in a small town and I don't
you know I'm not in the Bay Area and I
can't do it and I'm like it like does
not matter where you are if you can
really sit down and think about
something that you love and want to do
and really want to spend your time doing
and then you find a group of people I
mean it's never been easier you get on
the internet and like do a little
research you can probably find a group
of people that you can interact with and
then even if you have to take a long
drive or fly someplace like go
physically to a meeting that they have
and interact with some people and find
somebody else's project and volunteer to
help and if you can do those three
things if you can like figure out what
you're passionate about figure out a
place to go and then physically go there
and offer your help to somebody else I
guarantee you that's like a success and
the really easy recipe for success for
like getting involved in a community and
giving yourself a pathway to like
changing your life if you feel stuck yes
and that's advice that I wish someone
had told me a long time ago because it's
a simple recipe and anybody can apply it
it doesn't really
what you're into you just have to be
passionate about it and you have to make
the effort to go and like make a
connection with another person in person
and if you can do that stuff
I mean it's life-changing it's really
powerful you know inspires both people
you know and even now like I'm working
on great stuff but I need help all the
time and there's not that many people
that have the courage to come down and
be like look I don't know what I can
contribute but I really want to
contribute and I'm really passionate
about this stuff what can I do you know
that's a really great starting point to
go from as opposed to like I don't know
what to do can you help me you know
because you're not likely to find
anybody who's gonna take that and help
you you know but you can find someone
that will help you as long as you have
that common thread of both being really
passionate about something so yes you
know the first step is the hardest part
but it may also be the easiest you know
just what what would you what do you do
until you're so hungry you're like why
haven't I eaten in five hours you know
it's like find the things that you're
doing that you know really make you want
to do it yeah you know so yeah love at
first first first first and second
principles of connect to nature
understand our origins connect to your
purpose identify places to go to be able
to fulfill your purpose more more easily
with communities that are also doing it
and let's let's also unpack the other
ones here I mean now just in general it
seems like using mycelium is becoming so
popular now in everything is everything
from structural material still like
leathers to I mean set aside been being
magical ones so that's huge I mean
taking people mushroom hunting having
people actually do cultivation with it
teach us about that and also bees I mean
bees is another massive one you know
actually putting on a bee suit going out
there to the farm
seeing their importance in the
ecosystems yeah tell us about these two
so I mean my beekeeping schpeel is a
little shorter so I guess I'll do that
one first I'm I love to teach beekeeping
just from this standpoint that it kind
of ties in
all the different things that I like to
do you know I love science and there's a
ton of science going into researching
what's going on with bees but there's
also you know they're hugely important
in our food system and you can't you
can't learn about bees and become a
beekeeper without really taking a deep
dive into our food preparation are kind
of just the industry around producing
food for people because you learn all
this stuff about how people are you know
like what's in a lot of beekeepers are
really proud about their honey and to
tell you the truth I mean the honey that
I take out of my hives is a completely
different animal than the honey that I'm
able to buy in a store and I think that
there's just the realities of having to
pump I mean there's a lot of
inconsistencies with a natural product
so if you want to have a really
consistent product even if you're trying
to do the best you can I think sometimes
you have to like thin it out or you know
do something so that you can pump it
industrially but if you don't have to do
any of that stuff it becomes sort of a
different product so you know I'm I'm
sympathetic to some bee producers that
are really you know like really trying
to do the right thing with their honey
but it's not something that's terribly
difficult to do it takes a little bit of
a monetary investment but it's something
that will absolutely change your
relationship with nature and your
relationship with your food and it can
be a really fun community builder
because it's a lot of work sometimes so
you kind of really get a good there's
always saying like get your kids into
beekeeping and they'll never become drug
addicts because I'll spend all their
money on bees so it's a really kind of
catchy addiction that you can get
because they're fascinating to watch and
their their lives are governed by these
very rigid rules that you can take
advantage of like with using smoke or
you know using different Queen hormones
or something like that you can
completely control these organisms and
it gives you a really great hands-on
kind of
that in a computer system or something
of like you know what what is Mother
Nature on a granular level it's a really
great thing but it's kind of
unattainable for some people because you
need to have like a lot about their
space and you you know can't be in an
apartment and it takes several hundred
dollars to get started and so when
people are really into beekeeping I'm
like you should you know become a member
of a local beekeeping organization and
start there the great thing about
mushrooms is you don't have to start
from anything you can just literally
walk around I mean I found like coveted
edible mushrooms at the Rockridge BART
station so you can be in an urban
environment and find stuff that's really
fascinating it is a treasure hunt that I
am on all the time and I'm always happy
and kids love it I mean kids are even
better mushroom hunters than adults
because they're closer to the ground and
they can see the different angles and
stuff so it's great to go with kids
mushrooms don't run away from you
they're not typically poisonous by
touching them I mean you could eat them
and get sick but you have to metabolize
the mushroom to get sick there's no
amount of touching I mean maybe if
there's a you don't want to breathe the
ton of spores but if you're outside it's
never gonna be a problem
so it's a really accessible type of
science that you can do and then these
things have really unique chemistry so
some of them you cut them in half and
they start yellow and then they
immediately start turning bright blue
because of exposure to oxygen
some of them will change color when you
cook them or add acid or base I use
these mushrooms to make colorfast fabric
dyes in one of my classes which is a
really fascinating thing and you just
take something you found on the ground
and one of them you have to like do a
fermentation process and then you put it
in water and you boil your silk in there
and it becomes this like really
beautiful golden color and you know I
think we have a fascination with
mushrooms right now because there's all
these technologies and we've like
applied the science a little bit and
we're starting to find some of those
technological benefits but if you look
at that with plants or something it's
the same trajectory right like we get so
many of our pharmaceuticals from the
plant world we got so many of our foods
so many of our packaging materials you
know our paper bags are all from trees
or books and stuff like that so I don't
think necessarily mushrooms are that
unique other that we just haven't
explored them as much and so when we
really unpacked the potential that they
have which might be just as much as all
plants or all animals or something I
mean they have properties of both in
some cases so it's amazing you know they
may turn out to be even more versatile
than the plant world but I kind of see
it as being just like you know we're
discovering what was there all the time
yeah and you know so there's there's
nothing new happening it's been
happening the whole time I mean one of
the things that I love to talk about in
my classes is the only reason we have
fossil fuels on their earth is an
evolutionary gap between when fungus
figured out how to break down cellulose
and when it figured out how to break
down lignin which is the different
carbohydrate structure that makes
hardwoods hard and so the several
hundred million year process that it
took it to figure out how to eat that
that food source created this huge
amassment of material that then
fermented and became our fossil fuels
but we're not making anymore fossil
fuels these days because it's all being
recycled into our environment which is a
powerful thing you know we talk about
like you know how how environments in
the and the Sierras develop and there's
these meadows that will open up out of
all of a sudden and it's these mushrooms
that will go in there and infect the
tree roots and start eating that wood
and one of the byproducts of breaking
down wood and their metabolic way is
water so they can take a whole stand of
trees and basically turn it into a
vernal pond and if you know anything
about biodiversity is it's the edges of
different ecosystems that have the most
biodiversity so these organisms that can
go in there and create a you know
contained change of ecosystem and give
you different types of ecosystems that
are interspersed in one another that is
the like spice that gives us all these
different animals and it's these
different habitats that really get
specialization and you know it's this
kind of constant game that's going on
with these different animals that we get
all these different pharmaceutical you
know derivatives or foods or something
else artistic things so I I love the you
know applying this technology
but it's the reason why I think it's so
great as a teaching tool is it's so easy
and so approachable and so cheap yeah
you don't need any tools you don't
really need I mean don't start eating
mushrooms until you've been doing it a
while but you can go out there and look
at them and get involved I mean
mushrooms have a really cool community
around them there's a whole bunch of
people that want to go out and party and
you know talk about mushrooms on a
scientific level and then they want to
go drink a bunch of whiskey and talk
about art or music you know so it's a
really cool group of people to get
involved with and it's you know I
recommend it to anybody whether you like
mushrooms or not you know yeah these
these are also ways for us to to dive
deeper into things like deep deep time
because he realized that mushrooms have
been around for such a long time
evolving on the planet and we can learn
so much from how to best co-create we
ignore it just because they're
underground you know we ignore what we
can't see so that's most of it's
happening out of sight it's easy to
forget that that's happening yeah I love
these reimagining education
opportunities and workshops and classes
that are hands-on that are experience
show I love them so much and I love how
you use the words cooking is a
technology for sharing love I think it
is is what's her name so mean Nusrat the
woman who wrote salt fat acid and heat
she talks a lot about this stuff too you
know it's like our connection with our
food is very emotional and I think it's
a really powerful place to start with
people if you want to kind of touch them
in a way that'll make them want to
because it's it's great you know when I
teach somebody how to make pasta dish or
something it's very simple but then they
can go and share that with someone else
like I always want to make sure that
when you leave my class you're very
confident about being able to do at
least this one thing and being able to
reproduce that so I make everybody in my
class like do it without me telling them
what to do at the end of the class and
everybody like your graduation is that
you do it from the beginning to the end
you know after the whole class and then
you get to eat your little portion yeah
yeah but it's great you know doing it is
really is really special for people and
then all right so what is
the future of reimagining education
these experiences we have in the the
short video of the pipe yeah yeah so
we'll show explain this so as part of
our program so I want to make my classes
super you know I want everyone to
participate if they want to so a lot of
the classes that I do are free and open
to the public but that's not always good
for everybody I mean we're kind of you
know if you can afford to live in the
Bay Area you're probably at least likely
to need you know our help right I think
that educators like myself and the
programs that we're developing are
really important for people outside of
the Bay Area because people here have
already have a lot of resources so we're
using this which is in an open Tron's -
it's a liquid handling robot so if you
have to do a lot of like DNA analysis or
something you have to pipette a lot of
tiny amounts of liquid very accurately
and do a lot of different little wells
so this thing will do it automatically
for you it's one thing if you want a
high jacket to do real science or if you
want to use it for its intended purpose
but we kind of want to hijack it to do
something a little bit fun so we have
programmed this to just add liquid in a
form that will give you a little you
know artistic picture or something so
this was a test that we did just make
sure that it works but we're gonna
basically take these 96 wells on this
plate and we're just going to shrink it
way down so we get like a you know
whatever the thousand but it's not quite
a thousand it's like a thousand by 600
or something and it's gonna fit on a
well plate that's about that size that's
gonna have a guy on it and then that
little stylus is going to go and suck up
different aqueous solutions of bacteria
that we have engineered to express
different colors so in this case we're
using dyed with just water with some
food dye in it but in the future we'll
be using something that looks kind of a
little cloudy but it doesn't necessarily
have any color in it and when we grow it
when you stick it out on the growth
medium it'll start growing and it will
express those colors as they come out so
you can go in there and just create an
art piece by clicking on the different
pixels and selecting the different
colors that will correspond to the
different types of bacteria and then
we're gonna get a little a little
artistic vision so this is
obviously a very like you know chunky
monochromatic version of what I hope
people do which is create some really a
beautiful piece of art I think there was
one example on my website that has some
of the mushrooms that people were doing
but basically we give them a little
petri dish and a little watercolor
paintbrush and they dip it into a little
aqueous solution of bacteria and then
they make a little design and then what
grows and then when it's done it's like
invisible ink you can't see anything and
it grows and expresses the colors over
time and it mostly stays where you put
it but it will kind of grow a little bit
out so you can actually see in this one
those different colors they're as dark
as they are actually living bacteria
that are expressing these different
colors so we made a little palette so
you can see what the colors would look
like after they grew and then these are
the different little aqueous solutions
and so you can take that and and paint
it out and it's a really great way we
did this with San Francisco Art
Institute and a bunch of professional
artists came in and they did a whole
bunch of really cool you can see all
these pictures on counterculture labs
org but it's a really inspiring thing
it's a new opportunity to get people I
mean nobody talks about microbiology and
it's a really important technology
that's starting to affect all of our
lives it's in our food it's in our
medicines it's in our class well it's
not in our classrooms which is the big
problem and so people are kind of
hearing about this stuff and you know
the opioid crisis and new drugs and you
know cancer things and it's just like
nobody has any tools to evaluate whether
it sounds like BS or if it could be
something concerning I have to learn
about so we want to give people the
opportunity to learn about this stuff
but we don't want to scare them by
giving them something super complicated
or something they don't really
understand I mean a lot of people come
to these things they're like oh it's a
biohacking of them and I press the thing
and I don't really get it but if you
make your own art not only is it kind of
fun you get to see what happens you get
to you want to think about it a little
bit but then you want to show your
friends so it's that community thing I
was talking about you know it's not only
that I just did a thing and I'm like man
I'm did a thing that I'm proud of and
now I want to share that knowledge with
other people yeah so and there's a lot
of really cool I mean kids are great
about that but we do a program at
well the now-defunct Maker Faire where
we could extract people's DNA from their
spit so they'll spit in a little vial
yeah and then we put a little you know
stuff in there it's easy stuff it's like
hand soap and meat tenderizer and salt
and then you put isopropyl alcohol in
there and DNA is not very solid soluble
and isopropyl alcohol so it precipitates
out as these big stringy things and that
kids want to take the vials home and I'm
like that's gross but you know it's
something that they're proud of that
they made that they can reproduce you
know and so stuff like that's really
important and that's one of the reasons
I like working with food and mushrooms
is like you know the stuff that's that's
that has that potential for immediate
fascination but it's also really
approachable and cheap so you know we
want to open up stuff like this for
people over the internet so you just log
into a browser you make a design and
boom it can pipette out all the
different types of bacteria and give you
your own art piece and you can actually
enter the American Society of
microbiology sauger art contest through
our lab yeah and last year was the only
time that you could do it not as a
microbiologist that works in the
microbiology lab because we opened up
our community lab to let people do that
but now we're gonna be able to open up
so that anybody in the world that signs
into this website can do it which i
think is a really powerful engagement
tool and it's gonna let us you know I
don't think this is gonna change the
world necessarily but I think it's a
great example of the type of educational
engagement that we can do that will have
an impact you know so much more yeah but
it's more than just the one thing right
it's like it's something artistic it's
something shareable you know it's like
what I like to teach people how to cook
because they can immediately take that
and then like touch another person with
that it's not just enough to be really
passionate about something by yourself I
mean going back to the meat thing I had
this conversation with this other guy
who is like railing on me for using I
mean we use wild hunted pigs in my in
Mike butchering classes but you know
when I'm doing like a cooking class or
something like that I can't always get
like some pasture raised lamb or
something to work with sometimes I got
to go to the supermarket and he's like
well you can't do that and I was like
dude if you have the ability to eat this
stuff that's great but that's not gonna
save the world and it's not gonna give
you know I'm a really knowledgeable like
I have friends in the food business and
if I can't get that stuff on an easy
level what's the hope
that anybody else is going to be able to
do that so you can't just rail against
what other people are doing which is
just trying to live their lives and tell
them they're being part of the problem
because they're not doing this
completely impossible unsustainable
thing and that's where government comes
in it's like we have to make choices
that you know if everybody gets on board
it makes a lot of sense but nobody can
do individually yeah yeah yeah well
let's let's just let's just money let's
follow one of the thoughts there which
is like you're giving me this vision
about what it could look like we're
communities around the world are
starting to evolve more reimagining
education programs like we add the meat
up culture slowly take back it's it's
its place I mean looking back at these
villages and looking back at the tribes
looking back at us being able to pass
down really good lessons from the elders
in our in our in our groups and really
let the children find their purposes
connect to nature it does seem like the
the fee of the future is to be able to
have things like technology help us
identify in in very quickly the things
that follow our purpose in the
communities that are around us so we can
go and immerse ourselves in them get
hands-on experiences with them and that
I love that everything from kids to
adults to older people even being able
to do that and we should allow people to
have dignity in the things that they are
passionate about and feel like so many
times people are like oh if you didn't
have a college education and you know
your opinion is worthless or if you
don't have this certain kind of training
and that's just robbing people of the
ability to feel like they are like a
real participant and the things that
they're doing if you're waking up and
doing something every day
you know after about a few years you're
an expert whether or not anybody told
you that you are or you got a piece of
paper or you went to a certain school so
you know I really want to give people
permission to follow your passions and
do the stuff that you love and know that
simply doing the stuff that you love is
a pathway to becoming an expert and you
know there's some work we need to do in
our society to try to like detach
someone who has a lot of experience from
someone who's just gone to school
because I mean it cuts both ways it's
nice to have a lot of degrees and stuff
like that
but doesn't always help inform how
you're supposed to do your life you know
it's a very specific question in many
cases so a lot of people that's not
appropriate for it I think we should
give people the dignity to follow
whatever their real path is in life and
not expect them to have to jump through
these hoops that maybe don't make sense
for them yep yep and okay let's do the
two quick simulation questions on the
way out first is do you think we're in a
simulation
oh is that part of it I mean the in the
the Kantian version I guess I mean how
would we know I think
I think it's useful to think about it in
terms of it being a simulation in the
fact that we have a lot of power over
our experience in the world and there's
a there's a kind of thing so like I
started the business that I'm doing now
that I really love out of you know and I
used to say was like a fake it till you
make it kind of thing but I never really
faked it for anybody I was always really
clear to say you know this is the stuff
this is what I know you know these are
the limits of my of my knowledge and you
know I'm having an experience here where
I I see that everybody else has a unique
experience and if you have something to
bring to this table I want you to know
that there's a space for that here it's
not just me giving you knowledge like
this is a space we're creating so that
we can all share knowledge and I found
that if you're really clear with people
about where your education ends you end
up learning a lot and I haven't really
felt like I've had to fake anything
necessarily I'm really just kind of
taking the things I'm learning and
regurgitating it in a way that that I
think people really enjoy and I think
that that's important you know bringing
joy and play you know and kind of just
pleasure back into this process of
learning and self-improvement you know
it doesn't always have to be work so I
think it's it's useful to kind of choose
your passion and like you know find the
things that don't feel so much like work
and trying to use that as a guide to be
finding you know what's important so you
know if you want to think about it being
a simulation or something like that like
think about it as a game you know like
start start making choices that you know
like aim high level character and then
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in the world
you shouldn't have me prepare for this I
I get a real love out of gardening I
think that you know not everybody's
gonna grow all their food we're probably
all going to be part of the industrial
food system but if you can have a little
tiny plot of land I don't care if it's a
little like box outside of your window
or you know growing vegetables in your
front yard or something like that it's a
pretty beautiful experience to like grow
a piece of food and like bring it inside
eat it yeah it's a it's a really cool
experience even when it's bad like I was
growing these beets and I grew them to
dry and they just really concentrated
the tannins and so I like well I'm gonna
thin slice these and put them in a salad
and I had like itchy throat for a day
but I was also like I learned something
about growing beets
so you know that's I love that stuff
they know just watching stuff grow and
kind of being a steward of things as
they grow is something I find really
beautiful so yes do that with plants do
that with minds with minds I was gonna
say that yeah yeah be a good steward of
mine's growing like plants good like be
a good steward of Earth yeah all right
this has been a lot of fun yeah very
quickly occasion yeah yeah it's great
episode thank you so much for coming on
yeah absolutely glad you think so I've
had a blast thanks everyone for tuning
in we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
in the episode last know what you're
thinking go and share more content like
this about reimagining education about
having these little workshops in our
communities about going out and
connecting to nature and ourselves more
let's go and share that more their
communities friends families co-workers
people online I'll social me to get
talking about it and check out the links
in the bio below again that's Mario
Gaviota comm the counterculture labs org
and circuit launch now if anybody is
interested in taking in my classes or
learning how to set up a makerspace or a
workshop situation in their own hometown
I do a lot of consulting with that and
I'd love to help anybody set up if
that's if that's what you'd like to do
I'd like to help set people up so that
they can take my model and open it up
the new places because I can't be
everywhere at once so I'd really love to
connect with people they want to do this
in our hometown I love that a bunch of
trained of Mario's bringing people out
to be key bringing people out to
mushroom hunt I love that yeah that's a
huge to take what's special about the
Bay Area and make it everywhere I mean I
think unity nobody's going to church
anymore we got to find something so the
connection to nature again and yeah and
that's great Mario that's a great
recommendation for everyone as an action
item and also shout out to Ron Vargas
for producing and directing thank you
very much Ron and go and build the
future everyone's support though artists
all entrepreneurs organizations around
the world do you believe in sports
simulation our links are below
cryptocurrency PayPal patreon all of
those links are below design cool merch
and get paid for it as well and go and
build the future manifest your dreams
over the world thanks everyone for
tuning in a greatly appreciate see you
soon peace
[Music]